tonight the academy presents a very
non-squishy technical Achievement Award
to David Eberle Theodore Kim Fernando de
Goins and Audrey Wong for the design and
development of the Fizz T2 elastic
simulation system come on up team
[Music]
[Applause]
wow uh we'd all like to thank the
academy for this recognition Fizz T2 is
a result of a very tight and special
collaboration between tools research and
production at Pixar I'd like to thank my
parents my partner Cheryl and the tool
Sim team for their encouragement over
the years I'd also like to thank Haley
iben for supporting our Fizz T2 efforts
and the many many artists in the
simulation department for their
inspiring work which continues to push
the limits of our tools
hi I'd like to thank Brennan Smith for
helping make all this happen and my PhD
advisor Ming Lin for convincing me 20
years ago that rendering is boring and
simulation is awesome
yeah
and uh juban Davey and Zuzu spadashini
for giving me my first shot in the
industry by mistake 22 years ago
and most importantly uh Ivy and Rosie
for the love and support with everything
everywhere every day
I'd like to thank the pizza leadership
for supporting research and new
technology also I would like to thank my
family especially my mom and dad for
encouraging me and my wife Juliana for
being my best best friend and love of my
life and finally I'd like to dedicate as
I watch my son Marcelo thank you
thank you for this award eight years my
journey into simulation started with an
octopus on Finding Dory and now we're
actually doing jiggly pandas so I really
like to thank the simulation department
at Pixar For You Know supporting
pipeline I'm a production artist and I
use what these awesome guys produce
thank you for being my partners in crime
giving me everything I want and maybe
more and we should talk tomorrow
finally I'd like to thank my husband for
being there for me my two sons Aaron and
Adrian you know for bearing with moms
all our overtime hours and I'd like to
dedicate this award to them thank you
foreign
[Music]